In this lecture we give an overview of
text mining and analytics.
First, let's define the term text
mining and the term text
analytics.
The title of this course is called Text
Mining and Analytics,
but the two terms text mining and text
analytics are actually roughly the
same. So we are not going to really
distinguish them, and we're going to
use them interchangeably.
But the reason why we have chosen to
use both terms in the title is because
there is also some subtle difference
if you look at the two phrases
literally.
Mining emphasizes more on the process,
so it gives us an algorithmic
view of the problem.
Analytics on the other hand
emphasizes more on the result
or having a problem in mind.
We're going to look at the text data
to help us solve a problem.
But again, as I said, we can treat
these two terms roughly the same,
and I think in the literature you
probably will find the same.
So we're not going to really
distinguish them in the course.
Both text mining and text analytics
mean
that we want to turn text data into
high quality information or actionable
knowledge.
So in both cases we have the problem of
dealing with a lot of text data and we
hope to turn these text data into
something more useful to us than the
raw text data.
And here we distinguish two different
results
one is high quality information,
the other is actionable knowledge.
Now, sometimes the boundary between the two
is not so clear,
but I also want to say a little bit
about these
two different angles of the result of
text mining.
In the case of high quality information
we refer to more concise
information
about the topic,
which might be much easier for humans
to digest than the raw text data.
For example, you might face a lot of
reviews of a product.
The more concise form of the
information would be very concise
summary of the major opinions about the
features of the product.
Positive about, let's say, battery life
of a laptop.
Now, this kind of results are very
useful to help people digest text data,
and so this is to minimize the human
effort in consuming text data in some
sense.
The other kind of output is actionable
knowledge.
Here we emphasize
the utility of the information or
knowledge we discover from text data.
It's actionable knowledge for some
decision problem, or some actions to
take.
For example, we might be able to
determine which product is more
appealing to us all,
a better choice for a shopping
decision.
Now,
such an outcome
could be called actionable
knowledge because a consumer can
take the knowledge and make a decision
and act on it.
So in this case, text mining supplies
knowledge for optimal decision making.
But again, the two are not so clearly
distinguished, so we don't necessarily
have to make a distinction.
Text mining is also related to text
retrieval,
which is an essential component in any
text mining systems.
Now text retrieval refers to finding
relevant information from a large
amount of text data.
So I've taught another separate MOOC
on text retrieval and search engines,
where we discussed various techniques
for text retrieval.
If you have taken that MOOC, you
will find some overlap
and it would be useful to know the
background of text retrieval for
understanding some of the topics in
text mining.
But if you have not taken that MOOC it's
also fine, because in this more context
mining and analytics we're going to
repeat some of the key concepts that
are relevant for text mining.
But at the high level, let me also
explain the relation between text
retrieval and text mining.
Text retrieval is very useful for text
mining in two ways:
First, text retrieval can be a
pre-processor for text mining, meaning
that it can help us turn big text data
into a relatively small amount of most
relevant text data, which is often
what's needed for solving a particular
problem.
And in this sense, text retrieval also
helps minimize human effort.
Text retrieval is also needed for
knowledge provenance and this roughly
corresponds to the interpretation of
text mining as turning text data into
actionable knowledge.
Once we find the patterns in text data
or actionable knowledge,
we generally would have to verify the
knowledge by looking at the original
text data so the users would have to
have some text retrieval support to go
back to the original text data to
interpret the pattern, or to better
understand the knowledge or to verify
whether the pattern is really reliable.
So this is a high level introduction to
the concept of text mining and
the relation between text mining and
retrieval.
Next, let's talk about text data as a
special kind of data.
Now it's interesting to
view text data as data
generated by
humans as subjective sensors.
So this slide shows an
analogy between text data and non
text data and between humans as
subjective sensors and physical sensors
such as network sensor or
thermometer.
So in general, a sensor will monitor
the real world in some way it will
sense some signal from the real world
and then would report the signal as
data
in various forms, for example, a
thermometer would watch the temperature
of
real world and then will report the
temperature in particular format.
Similarly a geo sensor would sense the
location and then report
the location specification, for example
in the form of longitude value and
lattitude value.
Network sensor would monitor network
traffic or activities in the network
and report some digital format of data.
Similarly, we can think of humans as
subjective sensors that would observe
the real world
from some perspective, and then humans
would express what they have observed
in the form of text data.
So in this sense human is actually
a subjective sensor
that would also sense what's happening
in the world and then express what's
observed in the form of data,
in this case text data.
Now looking at the text data in this
way has the advantage of being able to
integrate all kinds of data together,
and that's indeed needed in most data
mining problems.
So here we are looking at
the general problem of data mining,
and in general we would be dealing with
a lot of data about our world
that are related to a problem.
And in general would be dealing with
both non text data and text data and of
course the non text data are usually
produced by physical sensors.
And those non text data can be also of
different formats -
numerical data or categorical or
relational data or multimedia data
like a video or speech.
So, these non text data are often very
important in some problems.
But text data is also very important,
mostly because they contain a lot of
semantic content and they often contain
knowledge about the users, especially
preferences and opinions of users.
So, but by treating text data as the
data observed from human sensors, we
can treat all these data together in
the same framework. So, data
mining problem is basically to turn
such data, turn all the data into
actionable knowledge that we can take
the advantage to change the real world,
of course, for better.
So this means that data mining problem
is basically taking a lot of data as
input and giving actionable knowledge
as output. Inside the data mining
module
you can also see we have a number of
different kinds of mining algorithms
and this is because for different
kinds of data we generally need
different algorithms for mining the
data.
For example, video data might require
computer vision to understand video
content and that would facilitate the
more effective mining and
we also have a lot of general
algorithms that are applicable to all
kinds of data, and those algorithms of
course are very useful,
although for a particular kind of data
we generally want to also develop
special algorithms.
So this course will cover specialized
algorithms that are particularly useful
for mining text data.